why does it always boil down to women  okay no don't say no because you see  what Nathan said I like you Nathan by  the way I appreciate girl but what made  me feel like you're not scared you're  more like scared to be stuck in one  because there's so many options out  there because you keep dipping your  cookie into the jars different jars of  different sauces so but here's here so I  think sorry the reason why you don't  want to come in I feel like the way you  explained to me to one jar is because  you're like ah because you saw the other  jar you saw the other day you're like it  might taste you said too many options  that's what you said earlier  let me